is it fair to provide Magnus Carlson a
personal Lounge where he can rest and
prepare for the game using a laptop
while nobody else has such an
opportunity Yan nepom nesi posed the
question that sparked a huge debate in
the chess Community after day one of the
2023 fiday World rapid and Blitz
championships shortly after Fabiano
kowana replied to the Tweet adding can't
be stressed more that everyone should
play Under the same conditions this
criticism isn't new for Magnus and
Carlson reportedly has had his own
Lounge in every preceding World rapid
and Blitz since 2016 for quote his own
security and privacy in response to the
unfolding debate magnus's father
confirmed to TV2 that Magnus does not
have access to a laptop in between the
games in his tweet Yan nepom nesi quoted
the famous line from George Orwell's
Animal Farm all animals are equal but
some animals are more equal than others
do you think it's fair for Magnus to
have access to his own Lounge